PETE LEPAGE: Well, welcome
everybody to another addition
"Chrome Apps Office Hours."
Today we've got Joe Marini,
who is joining us from Mountain
View and is going to
be talking about the new Synced
File System APIs.
Joe, why don't I pass it over
to you and you can give it a
little introduction?
JOE MARINI: All right,
I appreciate that
Pete, thanks very much.
Hi everyone, I am Joe Marini.
I am a developer advocate here
on the Chrome team and I work
on Chrome Apps, Chrome
Extensions, Chrome Web Store,
all things Chrome.
Chrome all the time,
Chrome everywhere.
And yes, today I'm going to be
talking about the Sync File
System The Sync File System
API is a new feature.
It's on the bleeding edge.
It's right now only in M27
Canary, so if you're going to
follow along with me here or
work on this on your own later
you want to make sure that you
have the version of M27 Canary
build on your computer.
So the Synchronized File System
is our API addition
that's layered on top of the
existing HTML5 File System for
Chrome Apps and Extensions.
And it basically allows you to
build apps and extensions that
synchronize data via files
using a cloud back end.
Now we architected it so it
can work with a variety of
cloud back ends.
Right now the one we
ship with is Drive.
So if you're using
Google Drive--
I'm assuming most of you are
familiar with Google Drive--
you can build applications
that sync files with each
other via the Google
Drive back end.
Now you might be thinking to
yourself, well, wait a second
the Chrome API already has a
synchronization method for
data, it's called Chrome
storage.sync.
How is this different
than that?
So look at it this way, Chrome
storage.sync is sort of our
synchronized analog to the
existing local storage
mechanism that you have
in HTML5, right?
You can store individual
objects, pieces of data, and
then using Chrome storage.sync,
you get the same
kind of functionality but it
gets synced between your app
or extension via the
network back end.
And those are for small
individual pieces of data.
So the Sync File System API is
different in that it's the
synced analog to the
HTML5 File System.
So for larger pieces of data,
especially those exceeding
several megabytes file size, you
can have the same feature
of syncing via files in addition
to the ability to
sync individual pieces
of data.
So with that, if you take a look
at the screen over here,
I've got the Sync File
System API up.
Now again, I want to emphasize
that this is still in
development.
It's in the Canary, so this
API might change slightly
between now and when you
use it in the future.
So at the moment we have a
couple of additions to the
File System API.
And it's important to point
out that when you use this
API, the objects you'll be
working with are pretty much
HTML5 File System Objects.
So for example, you see the
first API call there,
requestFileSystem, that takes
a call back just like the
regular HTML5 File
System one does.
And it gives you a File System
Object that you can use in
your callback to work
with files.
So that's how you request
the Sync File System--
is the requestFileSystem
API call.
You can also see what the
current usage and quota of the
Sync File System is
by using the Get
Usage and Quota function.
Just a bit of a caveat, right
now for the cloud side of
things, this function probably
isn't going to return the
right information.
We're working on that, but just
be aware of that if you
try this demo later on.
So that returns an object
called Storage Info.
And there's a couple properties
you can look at to
see how much storage you're
using versus how
much your quota is.
And there's a couple of other
API functions that have to do
with the status of files.
Because obviously, when you're
working with synchronized
files, there's going to be time
periods when a file is
going from one destination to
another, or it might have
changed and that change
needs to propagate
across all the instances.
So one of these is an
API call, one of
these is an event listener.
So let's go to the event
listener first, that's the
fourth API down there, and
that's the on-file status
changed event.
And you use this like
you use any other
Chrome API event listener.
We have an Add Listener call.
And the callback that will get
called when the file status
changed event fires is going
to give you a piece of
information about what
it was that changed.
So for example, it'll tell you
the file entry object of the
file that changed.
It will give you a status
of what the change was.
And right now the status can be
either synced, pending, or
conflicting.
The action is the sync action
that's going to take and it
could be either added,
updated, or deleted.
So it tells you what happened
to the file.
And the direction is the sync
direction for the event.
So these directions either could
be going from local to
remote or remote to local.
So the event tells you about
the file change event.
So going back a little bit,
we have the file status.
You can actually call this
function at any time on a file
entry that you have and it will
tell you what the status
of the file is.
Again, it's going to be
synced, pending, or
conflicting.
Currently, we don't have
an API to help you
with resolving conflicts.
We are actually considering
working on that.
So I figure that might come up
in the questions later, but
let me just get that out
of the way right now.
There's no dedicated API right
now to resolve conflicts, but
that is something that we're
looking very seriously at.
OK, so that's the API.
Let me take a look over here in
the Google Chrome GitHub.
So the sample app I'm going to
be showing you today is called
the syncfs-editor project.
And if you go to GitHub under
the Google Chrome category,
you scroll down here, you'll see
it's this guy right here,
syncfs-editor.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
And the link for that is
up on screen for those
folks who are watching.
JOE MARINI: OK, great.
So that link right there.
So when I click on it, you can
see this is the code I'm going
to be working with.
So if you want to follow along
or download it for later, this
is where you go to get it.
All right, let me jump over to
my Extensions tab because I've
now got this loaded
as an unpacked
extension in my Canary.
And I'm going to go ahead
and launch it.
And let me bring it down
so we can all see it.
OK.
So this is the app.
Now it's pretty straightforward,
basic
application.
On the right-hand side there,
you see an editing area.
On the left-hand side, there's
an area where file information
is going to show up.
And I've got two buttons
on the top there.
One is called Syncable, one
is called Temporary.
This particular sample app
uses both the HTML5 File
System's temporary storage so
that you can contrast its
usage with the Syncable
File System.
So let's just go ahead
and create a file.
I'm going to go to my text area
and I'm just going to
type, you know, this
is a file.
And I'm going to click
the Save As button.
And I'll save it as, let's
see, testfile1.txt.
I'll click Save.
Now watch the left-hand column
over there underneath where it
says Usage and Reload.
I'm going to click Save.
So you can see now that it's--
there's that little icon
showing that it's syncing.
And you could see-- oh, in this
case, it looks like have
a little bit of an error.
So I'm wondering if it's because
my authentication in
my Google Drive ran out.
But in any case, you can see
that we're taking advantage of
the status changed events there
to update the icon that
goes with the file.
So in this case, it looks
like the sync broke.
Let me just make
a change to it.
Click Save.
And it's applying the
local change.
Yeah, I think my authentication
probably timed
out on me in Google Drive.
But anyway, that's not
why we're here.
We're not here to--
let's just go over to the code
and see what's going on.
All right.
So this is the code for the
sample and let me start off by
taking a look at
the HTML file.
So this is the user interface
for the sample.
You can see that it's
an HTML file.
It's pretty simple, basically
just a bunch of divs that hold
the editor and the area where
we see file information,
that's pretty much about it.
There's also a couple of classes
that we build, one is
called the Editor class.
This basically handles all the
text editing for the sample.
So if you want to look in here
to see how we're doing, for
example, showing the dialogue
or building the editor,
that's up to you.
So there's another class we
have called the Filer.
This class, again, just a
bunch of utilities for
wrapping various file operations
that we have to do.
So let me show you first
the Manifest.
Again, all applications and
extensions for Chrome have a
Manifest file.
And to use the Sync File System,
I simply need to
specify the Sync File System
permission here in my
Manifest, and nothing
special beyond that.
So once I've got the permission
specified, I can
start using the API.
Now this here, the main .js
file, this is where we set up
the Synchronized File
System for use.
So here at the top we have an
event listener for when the
DOM content loads.
And what we're doing is seeing
if we support the Synchronized
File System.
So the support Sync File System
Boolean right here is
set by seeing if we're
in Chrome.
And if we've got the Chrome
Sync File System Object,
that's great.
And if we support it, then
we're going to call this
function here called Open the
Syncable File System.
So let's scroll down.
All right.
The function for opening the
Syncable File System
essentially checks to see that
we're in Chrome and then calls
the requestFileSystem function
that I talked about
earlier in the API.
Check to see if we got
any kind of error.
And assuming everything is OK,
we have this function here
called onFileSystemOpened.
And in onFileSystemOpened, we
just blog a message out to the
console saying, hey, we got the
file system, everything
seems to be OK.
We create a new editor, we
create a new file to go with
it, and then we're
off and running.
So let's go over to
the filer class.
And let's--
I'm just going to do a quick
search for the usage.
Show Usage, there it is.
And here in the Show Usage
function, this is where we're
calling the Sync File System's
Get Usage and Quota function
to see how much of our quota
we have and how much of it
that we are using.
And then let's go ahead and
take a look at the status
changed message.
So down here in this function
where we create the filer we
set up, assuming that we're
using the Syncable File System
instead of the temporary one,
we're setting up our event
listener to see if the file
status has changed.
And then if the service status
has changed, we have those two
event handlers.
And that's what's going to get
triggered when-- so, for
example, if I make a change to
the file on this side or if I
go to another instance of my
app running on another
computer and I make a change
on that side, this is the
event that will get triggered.
So pretty straightforward,
simple API.
From here on out it's just
HTML5 File System calls.
So, for example, if
we scroll down--
I'll just do a search for
the getRoot, fs.root.
And that is in--
hang on a second.
There we go.
Let me find the Save.
Where's the Save?
Oh, it's in the-- sorry,
it's in the utilities.
There's a utilities
thing in here.
And it's--
oh no, sorry, it's
in the editor.
There we go, there's the Save.
So here we have the methods
that are going to handle
things like opening, loading,
and saving files.
And you can see that from here
on out, it's just using
regular old HTML5 File
System APIs.
So here's the File System
root, getFile.
If you've done any work with
the HTML5 File System, this
will probably look
familiar to you.
It's creating blobs, saving
blob URLs out to the file.
So what we've done here
essentially, just to sum up,
is we've taken the HTML5 File
System and we've layered our
syncing architecture on top of
it so that you can build
applications that sync
files to and from a
remote cloud service.
This case, Google Drive.
In the future, who knows?
But using this API, once it goes
into Stable, you'll be
able to build extensions and
apps that built synced files.
PETE LEPAGE: Sweet.
Very cool.
JOE MARINI: Yeah.
Yeah, it is very cool.
I've been playing around with
it and seems to work pretty
well, assuming that you're
authenticated properly.
So I think now might be a good
moment to check to see if we
have any questions.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, I think
there are a couple of
questions up there.
JOE MARINI: OK, great.
PETE LEPAGE: So I'm looking at
one from Brian Tredaway in
Washington--
wants to know, can I read any
files from the user's Google
Drive with these APIs, or
am I limited to only
stuff I've put up there?
JOE MARINI: Yup, that's
a great question.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's a great
question, Brian.
So right now, and I think for
the foreseeable future, the
way that it works is--
again, this works the same way
as the HTML5 File System does,
so each app gets its own per-app
sandboxed File System
that just happens to be on
the user's Google Drive.
And it's important to point
out that the user doesn't
actually see the folder where
these files go by default in
their Google Drive interface.
PETE LEPAGE: Interesting, OK.
JOE MARINI: A power user can
search for the file and it'll
show up in the All Items view
and then they can see the name
of the folder.
Essentially, the name of the
folder is the same ID as the
app or the extension that's
creating the file.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
JOE MARINI: So that's how we
keep track of the instances.
But no, you only have access to
your Sandbox, which is the
same way that the existing
HTML5 File
System API works today.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool, OK.
So in that same way, then, if
the user wants to delete stuff
after they've installed the
directory, does it get deleted
automatically or do they
have to go find it
and then delete it?
JOE MARINI: Yeah, so what's
going to happen is--
so file management is done
either through your app or, if
you're app gets blown away, then
your data will get blown
away as well.
PETE LEPAGE: That's an
interesting scenario.
That's something that I think
we'd probably like to hear
feedback from you guys who are
watching today about this.
JOE MARINI: Yes, exactly.
And again, just to emphasize
that point even further, we're
still in Canary on this.
There's plenty of time for
you to give us feedback.
We'd love to hear from you on
our forums and on our D+ page.
So anything that you'd like to
see the API do or not do, or
do differently, please, please
speak up, let us know.
We want to make this useful for
all of you in your apps.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So this is my question, this is
not one from our list, but
you were talking about your
authentication expired.
How does authentication
work for this?
How does it know where
to go and what to do?
JOE MARINI: Great question.
Yeah, so by default, the Sync
File System works by using
whatever the signed-in
profile of Chrome is.
So if you're signed into a
specific profile in your
Chrome Runtime, that's the
profile it's going to use for
the Google Drive
authentication.
So assuming that you're
authenticated into Google
Drive and you've got everything
set up properly
that you normally would anyway,
which if you've got
Google Drive installed on your
machine, you've got your
credentials stored in Google
Drive, it's going to use
whatever the profile is that's
currently signed in.
PETE LEPAGE: OK, yeah.
That makes perfect sense.
JOE MARINI: Yes, exactly.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So A.A. from somewhere here in
the US wants to know are the
files synced in chunks
or as full files?
JOE MARINI: That's
a good question.
I'm not deeply familiar
with exactly how
the files are synced.
It's whatever the Google Drive
back end is using.
I believe they're synced
as chunks, but I'm
not entirely sure.
What I'll do is I'll
go check on that.
Do me a favor, just post that
question in our forum so that
way I have a marker for it
and I can respond so that
everybody can see the answer.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So here's another question
from me.
So if I go on one computer and
I create a whole bunch of
files and they get pushed up
to Drive and then I go to a
different computer, are those
files pulled down and sitting
locally on my other computer, or
are they only grabbed from
Google Drive when my app
goes and asks for them?
JOE MARINI: So no, they are
synced the same way that
Google Drive syncs
other files.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
JOE MARINI: So the cloud service
back end-- in this
case, Google Drive--
just syncs files
automatically.
It uses that feature to sync
the files, that way it
abstracts that notion away
from your app, right?
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
JOE MARINI: Your app doesn't
have to worry about, well,
when do I ask for
a file and did I
remember to ask this file?
And when did I last
ask for this file?
And so it lets Google Drive do
what Google Drive does best,
which is handle the mechanics
and the timing of syncing.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
JOE MARINI: And that's why that
event for handling the
status change is so important.
So that way it abstracts away
when things happen to you and
just lets you know hey,
this file changed.
Or when you change the file, you
don't have to remember it
to push things up,
it just happens.
So it's all handled in the
background for you by Drive.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Awesome.
Well, I think that's all
the time we have--
well, actually it's not all the
time, but those are all
the questions that
we have today.
So I want to say thanks Joe
for joining us and talking
about this and giving us a good
overview and a little bit
of a deep dive.
You're going to be
back next week.
We're going to be
talking about--
I keep forgetting this and
it's, like, we've been
talking about it.
JOE MARINI: It's the
interapp messaging.
PETE LEPAGE: That's what
it is, thank you.
JOE MARINI: So I'll be showing
you how to send messages from
one app to another, even to an
extension running inside
Chrome proper.
PETE LEPAGE: That's
a good one, yeah.
JOE MARINI: Yeah, so next week
should be interesting, we've
had lots of requests for this.
And we now have an API that lets
you message between apps
and extensions.
It's actually really
pretty cool.
So yeah, come back next week.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome,
so that's next week.
JOE MARINI: Thanks again,
for anybody who--
Yeah.
I'm sorry, what?
PETE LEPAGE: That's next week
4 o'clock Eastern, 1 o'clock
Pacific, and adjust time
zones for wherever else
you happen to be.
JOE MARINI: Exactly.
And thanks everybody for showing
up today to see the
Synchronized File System API.
Remember to go to the Google
Chrome GitHub.
Take a look at the Chrome
app samples repository.
Pull it down, start playing
with it, start hacking.
And we're excited to see
what you guys come up
with using our APIs.
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
All right, well thanks for
joining, everybody, and we'll
see you all soon.
Bye-bye.
JOE MARINI: Thanks.